je dis que j'ai attrapé le virus est
onoma parce que parce que j'ai toujours
envie d'y revenir
saab est difficile de partir mais quand
on sait qu'il faut partir pourquoi venir
et que ça c'est très important
on voit tout de suite le l'aspect humain
et puis bien sûr à ne pas ne pas
préciser le cadre idéal de travailler
dans ces conditions
sur une île qui est absolument
paradisiaque
partir d'ici non ce que si c'est trop
calme
on travaille dans les haines qu'on
travaille que sur calme au bout d'un
moment dans la pression le patron on
n'arrive plus à les respecter
ainsi que les ouvriers et on se respecte
plus soi-même
tu
c'est tout
le
situé au large de la baie de cannes les
superbes îles de lérins était inhabitée
quand ça tu en auras parti fonder un
monastère 9 405 en 1869
les cisterciens rachète il ils sont
maintenant une quarantaine de moine à y
vivre et y imprimer depuis une quinzaine
d'années le vignoble constitue leur
principale source de revenus pour la
garder la travail pour qu'ils puissent
progresser en s'entraidant donne à nous
de mener nos travaux avec un esprit
filial envers toi et un esprit fraternel
envers tous jusqu'au milieu des années
80 la ville n'était utilisé que pour
produire un vin de table destiné aux
moines
aujourd'hui environ trente mille
bouteilles d'un vin d'excellente qualité
sont commercialisées chaque année c'est
blanc fruité
c'est rouge puissant et fin sont issus
de cépages tels que chardonnay sierra
clairette mourvèdre ou unis blanc 2003
promet déjà d'être un excellent cru
disons que mon fils qui m'a aidé à la
rue des puits au printemps et puis j'ai
eu le résultat sec qui a sûrement
favorisé parce que les plus grosses et
l'ennemi de la vigne sont des
champignons qui ont besoin de dos
d'humidité est donc cette année n'ont
pas eu la partie facile en réfléchissant
sur quel créneau économique on pourrait
trouver et en même temps aussi de le
travail adapté un autre genre de vie
communautaire et monastique
donc on a réfléchi puis c'est là avec
des conseils extérieurs qu'on a dit oui
mais c'est vrai qu'on a un terroir avis
vu le peu de surface qu'on a parce
qu'actuellement on a sept hectares
60 c'est le maximum du maximum des
droits de plantation et même au maximum
je dire de l'emplacement physique à tous
exploités pratiquement on a réfléchi on
s'est dit on peut pas faire un vin
je veux dire un peu de tables de
consommation courante lé prix assez bas
parce qu'avec le peu finalement de
production qu'on a
économiquement cela nous demandera
beaucoup de travail et peu de résultats
peu de bénéfices ce qui n'était pas le
but recherché
alors on s'est dit autant table et tout
de suite sur un vin roman de de qualité
on a obtenu le but qu'on cherchait bon
ca 20 qui commence à avoir une certaine
reconnaissance qui est porté à peu dans
les milieux dans l'esprit chef par les
spécialistes du vin et en même temps ce
qui nous a aussi beaucoup influencé
c'est que le travail de la vigne
correspond bien à notre manière de vivre
dans ça permet de rassembler le frère de
faire beaucoup de travaux communautaires
donc on fait les vendanges ensemble il
ya des gros travaux de caves on les fait
ensemble et en même temps ce qui est
très bien dans notre vie c'est que le
cycle de la vigne et du vin suis bien
tout notre genre de vie liturgique
c'est quelque chose qui
c'est pas un produit instantané c'est un
produit qui évoluent sur le cycle d'un
an pratiquement
on a fait connaissance avec par le biais
d'amis du monastère de nos log
compétents qui ont bien voulu nous
suivre par le premier processus de
démarrage de la vigne la vinification et
puis surtout le travail de caves parce
que c'est là où là où le le métier
d'unification et le plus délicat est
donc c est nos locaux nous ont pris en
main nous ont suivis ils ont formé puis
on a eu aussi des des apports extérieurs
après pour le choix des vignes pour pour
la façon de conduire la vigne et au bout
de quelques années
ça y est on a commencé à évoluer dans le
temps le produit qu'on voulait faire
alors maintenant on me je commence à
maîtriser un peu ce métier la
vinification à vouloir aussi choisir les
gammes de vins qu'on veut obtenir des
arômes de fruits exotiques ananas
barbapapa caramel
pendant longtemps sellal irina une
liqueur forte à base de plantes qui a
assuré une part importante des revenus
de saint-honorat
vas-y sa composition à base de 50
végétaux différents et gardé comme un
secret d'état
il faut bien serré des produits
commencent
ah bon
c'était un frère convers plus personne
qui veut fédérer de la chimie avant
d'être monastère est celui qui a suggéré
de pouvoir réaliser
l'algérie n'a pour comme quand on a fait
comme puisqu'il y avait d'autres
réalités monastique qui faisait déjà
s'appuyer beaucoup sur la liqueur je ne
suis pas un jour j'ai passé la grande
chartreuse
voilà les finales b c'est tout et
démarrer les années 40
l'allée rina a connu une chute
importante de ses ventes depuis les
années 80 due en grande partie à la
baisse générale de la consommation
d'alcool fort en france
benoit tu as des colis a fait avec nous
tu sers la machine avec les faisons
attention aux bouchons pièce à ceux qui
ont déjà un jour précédent d'abord
passer de ça s'est fait offrir en
programmant la sortie de la machine
et puis en suisse les autres mais mettez
les collerettes tu mélo pierre l
la production viticole fait gagner
environ 130 mille euros par an au
monastère ce qui correspond à un gros
tiers des revenus de la communauté le
reste provenant des dons et des
retraites des anciens
ça
ouais
aliot il fait très très chaud très chaud
en hiver très froid n'était pas chaud
donc tu vois quelqu'un m'a dit hier que
la chaleur la vague de chaleur qui vient
de l'europe centre
les moines cisterciens de lérins
appartiennent à l'une des trois branches
issues de l'ordre fondé un site haut en
1098 robert de molesme un moine
bénédictin s'était alors installé en
pleine forêt bourguignonne avec quelques
compagnons dans le but de revenir à une
ascèse plus grande et à une pauvreté
plus strictes
les cisterciens décidé de se consacrer
principalement au travail manuel
agriculture artisanat mêmes industries
au 19e siècle alors que les bénédictins
firent toujours la part belle aux arts
et une travaux intellectuels
e
oh
le fondement dans une vie monastique
suivant la règle de saint benoît et
c'est toujours valable aujourd'hui c'est
ce qu'on appelle la lectio divina qui
est donc davantage une méditation aussi
savoureuse de la parole ça fait partie
de la règle de notre programme de chaque
jour et comme dans chaque élément de
notre règle il ya aussi des tentations
qui vont se mêler c'est à dire parfois
sous d'excellents prétexte on peut
mettre de côté 7cette lectio divina peut
être sous prétexte de faire une lecture
plus intéressante d'elle mais ce que je
remarque c'est que chaque fois que je
fais ce temps de lectio gratuite
de fait d'une manière ou d'une autre
dans la journée ça peut ressortir
la journée est rythmée par cet office
religieux de l'aude jusqu'à accompli la
messe a lieu à 11h15 du matin les repas
sont pris en silence à l'ecoute d'une
lecture choisi par le père abbé celui ci
est élu à vie par ses frères
notre père le nomme l'existence et qui
renouvelle sans l aval dans cet accord
nous aujourd'hui le succès constant et
plus haut
le 2 octobre le quotidien et le vent de
face
nous avons notamment à la survie comme
un art est une famille modèle
il ne serait ce de comptes hantise
d'être des centres où le moment encore
même sous le patronage 50 ans il faut
que nous avons dû rassurer notre plaisir
page main tout ce qui nous entoure
à présent les sens inné
c'est important dans ce canton et mots
toute la population du district sans que
l'autorité est il temps pour nous aussi
de ce grand show de notre notre place de
celles qui ont consacré à la prière à la
liturgie à l'avancé de saint-honorat
étant situé dans une île paradisiaque
les retraitants affluent de toute la
france l'hôtellerie du monastère d'une
capacité de 40 lits ne désemplit pas les
mois les meilleurs sont toujours hiver
le trentin il ya pas trop du monde
l'îlot si elle est plutôt tranquille et
la notion n'est plus vivable pas
d'arrêter c'est pas trop adapté pour les
retraites spirituelles
ah oui mais si il y à un bon pourcentage
de personnes et qu'ils viennent
exactement avec des questions val eu des
problèmes à résoudre
sinon il ya un autre une autre partie
qui vient pour déjà pour faire un litre
de silence et de prière sans problème
particulier mais pour vraiment faire
silence prier
ils ont besoin d'être écoutés c'est
l'une des choses de base et de
l'hôtellerie c'est d'écouter recevoir
sans juger les personnes ayant des lieux
dans lesquels il sera jugé
il faut la vie qu'ils veulent et dans le
même temps ils ont quelqu'un qui a comme
et tâche de les écouter ça veut pas dire
résoudre les problèmes et ce des deux
côtés et je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
gens qui manquent de de la relation
c'est la relation qui manquent
on a besoin de l'autre
on a qui nous arrive c'est une tare émis
par exemple si on se lance dans une
machine à 10h30 il est il est propre
elle peut être donner un hôte
d'abord une solitude affective qu'il
faut savoir vivre à longueur de journée
et à longueur de dan et toute la vie il
faut faire attention à certaines choses
mais en même temps la vie affective
et quand même supplié par une vie
fraternelle une vie spirituelle
peut-être plus riche et plus conséquente
et plus formatrices mme vos informations
personnelles pour vos croître dans la
maturité humaine
la sexualité est un sujet qu'on
n'abordait pas en groupe un bon parce
qu'on n'est pas peut-être pas tous au
même niveau
moi je ne sais pas du tout comment le
frère qui vit à côté de moi dans sa
cellule à côté de la cellule vit sa
sexualité ça me ça ne me regarde pas
c'est un sujet qu'on aborde avec une
personne précise et ça ne regarde pas
les autres et c'est vrai que c'est il
faut savoir vivre sa sexualité en tant
que moine ça c'est moi c'est important
les mois passent à regarder et puis
aussi parce que le mois ne doit autant
petit peu se dessaisit de sa personne se
déposséder de lui-même donc de la
coquetterie par exemple de se voir
ailleurs mais pas au moment où je me
coupe les cheveux puisque doit faire
totalement confiance à as enfin quoi
faire puisque dans la règle de marquer
comme moi n'a rien propre même pas la
disposition de son corps donc c'est pas
du tout des paroles en l'air
ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui c'est les
choses désagréables s'occuper des
impayés
mais quand il dit continuer à s'occuper
des impayés géré passerelle en la
matière
je vous laisse le tout ça c'est la
banque ait eu quelques soucis les verrez
st je pense qu'il faut éviter deux
pièges le tout angélisme
c'est à dire d une communauté hors du
temps et hors des contingences de ce
monde c'est le premier écueil est le
deuxième écueil voir le monastère et
faire du monastère tout économique et
nous il nous faut vraiment garder les
deux pieds
ces deux symboles prière et le travail
quand on regarde le monastère c'est
quand même un microcosme qu'il faut pas
regarder en lui-même mais voir cela
aussi à l'échelle de des enjeux mondiaux
et de l'économie mondiale enfin pour
casser ma ma façon de voir les choses et
donc qu'on est interpellé par ce qu'on
appelle le développement durable qui
prend en compte la nature les besoins de
l'homme et à mettre en place comme
quelque chose qui perdure dans le temps
et ça ça me semble important du fait de
leur situation de vigiles de la baie de
cannes les moines dure souvent cohabiter
avec des militaires dans la partie
fortifiée du monastère
tout était aménagé ici pour pouvoir
vivre de manière renfermé si ça n'est
pas un puits c'est une citerne donc il y
avait suffisamment d'eau pour vivre pour
pouvoir vivre en étant enfermés
éventuellement s'il y avait un siège
militaire ou quelque chose comme ça donc
là nous entrons dans le réfectoire si si
vous vous rappelez le réfectoire de la
communauté finalement c'est très
semblable c'est une pièce longue
simplement il manque les tables et les
bancs pour manger puis un peu de
revêtement sur les murs parce que ça par
contre je pense que ça n'a pas du tout
changé par rapport aux moyennes à ce
qu'est ce que font les moines dans un
réfectoire deux choses
ils se nourrissent en mangeant des
nourritures matériel et ils se
nourrissent aussi en écoutant une
lecture les moines ont vécu dans dans
ces lieux en fait de façon stable et
permanente de la fin du xvème siècle du
milieu du 15e siècle jusqu'à 1788
alors c'est peut-être dans cette
cervelle qu'il faut faible
le preuve de plus d'imagination cette
chapelle était quelque chose
d'extrêmement luxueux ce dont n'a plus
du tout l'impression aujourd'hui il ya
une partie du mur qui s'effondrait donc
elle était beaucoup plus sombre aussi
donc
elle était réservée à la communauté il y
avait le long des murs une quarantaine
de staël en marqueterie auxerre et puis
il y avait ici un grand hôtel avec des
reliques 7 vous
et montre plus haut que le premier étage
des soldats et donc il y avait des
communications sonore et en has
une lettre du xviie siècle où les moines
se plaignent que leur fils qui sont en
train de célébrer l'office
ils entendent les soldats chanter ou
parler on ne sait pas très bien ce qu'il
disait parce que le document dit au nom
des mois de ce qu'ils disent et ce
qu'ils chantent ne nous ont pas le
mettre par écrit
de saint-honorat de lérins elle sortit
une impressionnante ligne et d'apôtres
dont saint patrick
le célèbre évangélisateurs de l'irlande
ici c'est sûrement l'endroit à la fois
le plus beau et le plus intéressant
historiquement donc c'est la chapelle de
la trinité qu'on voit là avec aussi donc
toutes sortes de ruines au tour qui sont
les traces de l'implantation des moines
au cinquième siècle au moment où le
monastère a été fondée par par
saint-honorat c'est une chapelle dédiée
à la trinité les moines de lérins avait
à la fois une grande dévotion pour
l'activité est très soucieux de
l'orthodoxie de leur foi en la trinité
le fait qu'elles soient dédiés à la
trinité explique très saine helmand il y
as troisième site c'est à dire qu'il est
en forme
enfin deux trèfles m'avait donné reste
bonne chose mais c'est fragile à
répandre le père à benoni toutain que
non mais j'y vais je mets père abbé dom
à ce que c'est important
y a que dix marches ou là mais c'est un
2h50 et attentionné compagnie de barco
quitte à nous c'est à dire que les
moines en pause il ya quatre ans la face
au panier festivals à cannes à la jetée
albert edwards billetterie le premier
kiosque c'est le nom qu'a écrit
saint-honorat au dessus du lot second
parce que tout
tout à l'heure j'ai posté par une pop
paris mais il m'a dit les rays il faut
pas demander si de dire s il y en a qui
sont chacun d'eux le premier voulait
faire une journée de retraite et se
monte à l'autre hymne et puis a passé la
journée en dépouillant comme cela
procède à la sainte marguerite il n'a
pas rejoint bay le dimache donc il ya du
monde décevoir nous on est vraiment rond
on tourne 300% 14 au revoir madame
d'assises ouais donc c'est comme ça
c'est vrai que c'est un lieu très
touristique ça n'est pas une gêne à deux
conditions que soit préservé
l'environnement au niveau végétales et
patrimoniale et donc il faut surveiller
ce côté là et puis que soit préservé le
climat spirituel de l'huile et ça peut
se faire par une une régulation du
tourisme
c'est vrai que ça n'est pas facile
contrairement à toutes les communautés
qui était sur des îles qui ont déménagé
depuis le 9e siècle jusqu'à relativement
récemment nous on a toujours décidé de
rester dans cet endroit qu'est chargé
d'histoire et donc il faut qu'on
travaille et qu'on veille pour le pour
le maintenir dans dans un bon état à la
fois environnementale et spirituelle
c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui il faut lutter
aussi contre tout l'argent que pourrait
apporter ce tourisme que c'est peut-être
la chose la plus difficile
rondement